Welcome to the strength test.
Obviously, the ice block chop.
I'm going to take
your completed knives
and I'm going to
smash them quite
vigorously and enthusiastically
into these big chunks of ice 10
times.
And I want to see what the ice
is going to do to your knives.
Ethan, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's make snow-cones.
My main worry is
that the ice will
split open any seams on my
blade that didn't weld properly.
[rock music]
Good god, man.
[dramatic music]
Well, Ethan, your edge held up
pretty well for the most part.
That heavy convex helped you.
The big issue I have is the
handle, the way it tapers down.
When I was striking,
I started out here
and I ended up with a
knife like this in my hand.
If it wasn't for the
little hook back here,
it would have gone
out of my hand.
Overall, your knife
survived the ice.
Good job.
Ron, how are you feeling?
Little nervous.
It's all right,
I'm not nervous.
It will be OK.
[nervous laughter]
RON: Watching Ethan's blade
perform, I'm feeling good.
We both used a
chain and sprocket
on each side of
the blade, so I'm
ready to see mine perform too.
[rock music]
Oh, Ron, there's
definitely a big issue here.
Material sheared right away
from the sprocket steel here.
When you first took that
chain, you put it in the forge
and heated it up cherry red and
then set it aside, not built
up forge scale on that chain.
I would like to have
seen you go ahead
and actually start
trying to clean
that up right off the
bat, because there's
that forge scale.
There's nothing
holding this together.
Ron, your blade has
suffered a catastrophic blade
failure in our strength test.
However, it doesn't mean
you're out of this competition.
Liam, your blade still has to
go through the strength test,
and it would seem that
both of your fates
ride on whether or not
Liam's blade can hold up.
[dramatic music]
Even with Ron's
catastrophic failure,
they still have
to test my blade.
I used the wrong
metal for my edge.
I know it's going to pick up
some damage against the ice,
I just don't know how much.
I could still be going home.
[rock music]
Well, Liam survived.
You've got a couple of
small rolls on here,
but overall the edge
held up very well.
The only thing is the handle--
it's on the narrow side.
You can see it actually kind of
got into your tang a bit there.
And the texturing is a
nice touch and a good idea,
but smoothing it out
would have helped a lot.
Liam, your blade held
up, congratulations.
Ron, unfortunately that
means that your blade
did not make the cut.
I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
Thank you.
RON: Being here
meant a lot to me.
I didn't make it all the
way, but when I get home
I'm going to get all my kids,
give them all a big hug,
and practice with
some more chain.
This time I won't heat
the chain as long.
[music playing]